publisher of its publication the western
journal
a graduate of the university of
washington he is the founder of citizens
united
and a past executive director of young
america's foundation
where he oversaw the preservation and
expansion of the reagan ranch
he served as advisor to general excuse
me he served as advisor
to the presidential campaigns of george
w bush bob dole
steve forbes and mike huckabee mr brown
has written for numerous publications
including human events the san francisco
chronicle and the washington times
and he's a frequent guest on television
including on fox news's tucker carlson
tonight
the abc's prime time and nbc's today
show
he is author or co-author of six books
including prince albert the life and
lies of al gore
slick willie why america cannot trust
bill clinton
and most recently big tech tyrants how
silicon valley's stealth practices
addict teens silence teach and steal
your privacy
please help me in welcoming mr floyd
brown
thank you you know before i get started
here i just want to
say how wonderful it is to be back at
hillsdale college
i have been an admirer of hillsdale for
so many years
and i really admire them for one reason
and that is their continued
commitment to timeless principles
and i'm really honored to join with
all of you today
so in the spring of 2019
i got into an argument with a member of
the
executive team at western journal
and we have been experimenting with new
ways to use
facebook's
marketing in e-commerce
and uh you know i have most i have 85
employees at liftable media and most of
them are younger than me i'm the oldest
guy in the in the building
and they know so much more than i do
about facebook and uh
in particular uh this young man i was
arguing with his name's ford jordan
we had a dispute and
it was really over
one sentence ford came into my office
and he said you know
i can use facebook to predict
when a woman will get pregnant
and i said what i mean i was incredulous
don't don't tell me that ford he said no
i
can predict using facebook's marketing
algorithms
when a woman will get pregnant and i
said that can't be true
that absolutely just sounds
crazy well
our argument ended there but about four
months later
it became public that facebook had been
out vacuuming up data
from ovulation apps you know what
ovulation apps are
these are applications that women have
on their smartphones
women usually that are trying to get
pregnant
and they enter their sexual cycle
or their menstrual cycle into the app
and they check
their temperature every day and the
whole purpose of the app
is the app is telling you when's the
perfect time
to have sex so that you can get pregnant
and facebook was buying this data from
several of these apps
so i was the one who lost the argument
obviously
because the truth was using facebook
data
for jordan could predict and could
market to
women that were going to get pregnant
now my first simple question to you
today is do you think the women
that were using those apps
with their most private details
do you think the women understood when
they clicked that
terms of service button when they
downloaded that
app to their smartphone do you think any
of them
understood that that data was going to
be marketed
it was going to be sold to others and it
would be
part of the nexus used by facebook to
connect with their other data in order
to enhance a marketing profile
so that people could serve them ads
i doubt it i doubt it in the same way
that most people don't ever read the
terms of service for different apps
that they download i mean did you read
the terms of service of
the google maps app or did you read the
terms of service of the facebook app or
the yelp app
or any of these apps that might
currently be on your smartphone
chances are you didn't most of us don't
and we find these little
smartphones to be so unbelievably
productive in our lives
you know the truth is is that uh um
when gene roddenberry
first had star trek and he had these
little
communicators i mean what we have today
is
so much more amazing than anything that
they had
uh back then and and and even in his
grandest imagination probably
wouldn't have understood all of the
enhancements to productivity that came
as a result
of this little device called
the smartphone so our nation's
productivity may have exploded but
there's also
a number of very serious
and very important things i want to talk
about that follow
on from all of us using
these little devices called smartphones
so i'm often asked why did you write the
book big tech tyrants
and really the reason i wrote it was
because i've had a front row seat to
watch
the evolution of these different
technologies as they've
moved along facebook opened to the
public
in 2007 2008 and uh
we were very early to the whole facebook
revolution we
launched our publication called western
journalism at the time it's now called
western journal
and we were serving news into that
facebook
infrastructure early on and as a result
we
we grew amazingly i mean
uh the truth is is uh uh
we were able to use that very
productively so
i'd say the most important reason i
wrote the book is because
most americans really don't understand
the threat
of this technology and
um they don't understand that
the threat was the the the technology
was developed
specifically to be addictive
and they also
don't understand that in addition to
being
addictive much of big tech is actually
used to brainwash users
i know dr robert epstein is going to be
here tonight to speak to
you and he has done much really
great work in this area about how these
technologies are
actually used to brainwash and change
the ideas of people that are using them
and you know
the other thing i think that's important
to understand is that many people have
been the victims
of scams they've been ripped off their
identity's been stolen
and much of that has been done as a
result
of big tech
so um why don't we start with uh
addiction how does big
tech addict people now
uh a lot of us in fact how many of you
know somebody that's addicted to
technology and addicted to their
smartphone
any okay that almost every hand in this
room's raised
i uh particularly like this story
because this is about a woman
who was looking at her smartphone and
she
walked off of a cliff and she was stuck
there for 13 hours
she was so addicted to her smartphone
that she didn't see a cliff in front of
her
now the end of the story was pretty good
because she lived
but there's many people that have died
because they walk into traffic
they do all kinds of other crazy things
they they're they're in auto accidents
all because
of this unbelievable addiction
to their smartphones
but the truth is it's children that
suffer most
children really bear the brunt of this
you know i don't know how many of you
know the story of
tyler clemente but um tyler was a
student
at rutgers university new brunswick and
he jumped
to his death from the george washington
bridge at the age of 18
back in 2010 and the reason
that he jumped to his death was because
his roommate had used a webcam
in the dorm room and he'd used
another computer from another student
and they had filmed surreptitiously
tyler kissing another boy and
he was so distraught by this because
they turned around and they
posted the video of that kiss
on social media and
so he jumped to his death he killed
himself
because of social media or the story of
phoebe prince she hanged herself after
nine
teenagers harassed her for months on
social media
see social media it magnifies
and it increases the effects of bullying
especially on children
you know it's a really interesting
that uh psychologists and
psychiatrists that have been studying
this have actually coined a term
as a result of it it's called facebook
depression
and it really has to do with we we see
others
lives and you know they're they're
for example they're posting pictures of
themself on the beach
in hawaii we think wow you know
what a great life but what they don't
post
are the pictures that uh
took to get to hawaii let's say they had
to shovel out their
their driveway of snow and
you know it took two hours to shovel
that snow so they could back out of the
driveway
and get to the airport you know you
never see the bad in life on facebook
people only post the most beautiful
things i mean
you know a lot of people like to post
pictures of meals that they've eaten
well the meals are always at high end
restaurants it's always the best meal
you've ever seen
and you don't you know they never post a
picture of oatmeal that they had that
morning for breakfast
the truth is is it makes you have a
distorted
picture about the lives of others
and so as a result people that use
a lot of social media people that spend
a lot of time on social media
suffer depression as a result of it it's
not healthy
so
there's been a number of studies of how
it actually can
change the brains of teens
that spend a lot of time on social media
and it's very very very
addictive and uh you know
most people don't realize that now
by the age of four most children can use
a keyboard
well i'm a baby boomer i'll admit it
okay boomer i uh the truth is i learned
how to use
a typewriter when i was in high school
and the thought that by four most
children can use a keyboard to me is
just astounding
by age seven most children have their
own mobile phone
as early as six most children
have seen online pornography
and you know the truth is is that uh
we talk about this a lot in uh
in uh working online the the truth is is
that pornography
is the profit engine
of big tech and it's the profit
engine of many of the big tech companies
i mean for example we could do an
extended discussion on the page
on on the website called back page
which is now shut down it was shut down
by the federal government
because it was a place where they were
trafficking children
and there was prostitution involved and
a lot of
of other things routinely google
made a billion dollars a year
off of backpage and in fact the reason
backpage wasn't shut down earlier was
because
google had actually been helping to fund
the defense of
backpage so when you look behind the
veil of a lot of these companies what
you'll find is that many of them
are very happy to get people addicted to
pornography
because they become the the kind of
launch pad to move you
on to pornography
the um
the truth is is that by 10
most children are watching an inordinate
amount of videos on facebook
and youtube by 11 or 12
many of them have their own facebook
pages even though they have to lie to
get them
because through the terms of service
they're not old enough to have their own
facebook page but they have them anyway
and by 12 many are living in a virtual
world
many are streaming video online and in
fact many of them are actually
stripping naked for these videos
so children
and this is what makes it so
unbelievably difficult
children just don't
understand the consequences of this kind
of behavior
they don't understand how it's going to
affect them later in life
they don't understand the follow-on
effects of too much
media consumption and it isn't
surprising
that all of the different notifications
and
and beeps and buzzes that you have on
your smartphone
those were all developed by gaming
companies
so silicon valley went to
las vegas they went to the gaming
industry and they studied the way
gamblers get addicted to slot machines
and they use that technology in the
smartphones
in order to addict you to that
smartphone
so it's uh it's really uh
all intended to increase your time on
that smartphone
everything is to pull you in i you know
i understand it i know
all of the tricks that they use and i'm
still addicted to the darn thing
i mean it's hard to pick up a phone and
not spend time on it because
it's you know giving you all this input
and it's speaking to your brain and it's
uh you know it's like
i had it explained to me like this once
you know all of us know that when we eat
sugar it's not good for us
right but all of this feedback from our
smartphones is like
sugar on the brain it it
it boosts our endorphins and it and it
gets us caught up in this
world that uh is uh is very addictive
and um it can have long-term
psychological impacts
so big tech the other thing that they do
is they silence speech now
um big tech uh when i first started
giving this talk when i when i actually
first
wrote my book book on big tech tyrants
uh we hadn't lived through the 2020
election
so people you know now i think are
more cognizant they're more
understanding of the way
big tech has been manipulated to control
speech
and control ideas but a couple of years
ago
in the 2018 cycle for example they were
already
very actively engaged in this but most
people
didn't understand it and
the truth is is that you know i'm not
surprised
that even president trump who is really
great at using social media
in the end found that these particular
companies
are impossible to beat so
one of the things i like to talk about
is the tale of two candidates from
2018. so
these were two really interesting
candidates of the 2018 cycle
both were articulate females
both had parents that were born abroad
so they were both from
immigrant families they were both both
born in the 1980s so they were younger
they were new they were
you know potential leaders of the future
and both had graduated from
prestigious colleges so they were very
similar in a lot of ways you would
probably
judge these two candidates as being
quite similar
well big tech didn't see it that way big
tech
thought these candidates are polar
opposites so
they treated these two women completely
differently
polar opposite treatment so
candidate a had her videos banned by
facebook
and they were suppressed by youtube
candidate b became an immediate social
media star
and her videos were boosted until they
had millions and
millions of views candidate a
um banned video is the story of her
family escaping from the killing fields
in cambodia it's a very compelling story
candidate b posted many videos that were
viewed
millions of times so
so candidate a effectively
had her ability to reach people online
restricted while candidate b was boosted
and her content was everywhere
it brought her donors from around the
country and she became one of the top
online influencers so while you would
think these two candidates were very
similar
big tech treated them absolutely polar
opposite
so i'd like to show you a video here and
as you can see
it it is currently even to this day
suppressed
and this is the video of elizabeth hang
in cambodia under pol pots khmer rouge
being young and single often meant a
gruesome life
and likely death
they approached my father and in order
to save his life
he said he was about to be married
they asked him to whom he pointed to the
prettiest girl that he saw
having never spoken to her before
the soldiers approached her and she said
yes
they got married the very next day
41 years later they're still the
happiest couple
i know great things can come
from great adversity
[Music]
fresno's home but america's booming
economy never made it to our district
empty buildings homeless desperate
people
our congressional district is one of the
very poorest
in america for 14 years
we've been represented in congress by a
nice man
jim costa but so little has changed
look around this is what we can still
expect to see
14 years from now unless we plan for a
better future
when we were young my mother picked up
coins off the floor
at the mall to buy us a happy meal when
we did well
in school they worked long long hours
at the local grocery store they still
run
all that they made they saved for our
education
elizabeth is the hardest working student
i have had in my 33 year teaching career
and she is the first sunnyside high
school graduate to have earned her way
into stanford university
studying at stanford wasn't enough
elizabeth was also elected student body
president
next came an mba from yale
she spent time on the staff of respected
u.s congressman ed royce in washington
learning why most of the time in d.c
nothing happens
nothing we've given jim costa
14 years to bring us a better life
has it worked in those same 14 years
elizabeth hang excelled in high school
graduated stanford
was elected student body president there
got her mba from yale
learned what's wrong with dc helped her
brother start a very successful business
then turned her attention toward making
our lives
better same 14 years
which person is most likely to improve
our future
i'm 33 i have the energy and drive to
bring us
a better future not just talk about it
do it break the log jam and restore
our water infrastructure reform
immigration
the right way vastly improve our
education system so more of us can go
to great schools everyone told me that
i'd never go
to stanford or yale or work for congress
just like they tell you that our homes
and our cities
will never get better everyone
is wrong great things can come
from great adversity
i'm elizabeth hang and i approve this
message
so elizabeth hang is the
candidate number one in this story of
suppression
and you probably can all guess why she
was so suppressed
by social media she was suppressed
because she dared to tell the story
of what her family had experienced in
the killing fields
of cambodia because that's not
acceptable and it's not part of the
narrative that is
acceptable to big tech and so here's
candidate b okay
the one that saw all of her
content boosted she became
instantly known all across the country
she did go to a prestigious college but
not nearly as prestigious
as stanford and yale in my opinion
but you can see big tech
was able to kill the candidacy of
elizabeth hang
and they literally
made aoc who she is
but yet if you look at those candidates
beforehand
they're very similar in a lot of ways
the only difference is one was a
conservative
and one is an outlandishly
far-left socialist and so
big tech promoted one
and big tech suppressed the other
and that's happening all the time
all the time so uh
i know this from firsthand experience
uh i lived through this myself with our
own company
the the truth is this is uh
the algorithm change impact on
publishers
so in 2016
liftable media had content seen
in the facebook news feed 11
billion times that led to over 150
billion
impressions on our website but once
donald trump was elected
and once uh big tech turned to mark
zuckerberg and said
you know you're the reason donald trump
was elected
you allowed him free reign on your
facebook platform and you allowed him to
communicate his message to people on
facebook
unhindered you've got to stop that
and mark zuckerberg snapped into line
just like all of the other big tech
companies had
and began to progressively
suppress more and more content online
so uh you know there are so many
examples of this i could just talk about
this forever but
one i like to give is just go home
later and google the name franklin
graham
okay and most of us know who franklin
graham is he's the son of billy graham
the
great evangelist probably the most
well-known evangelist in the
in the history of the country and uh
he's
he's stepped into his father's shoes he
runs
samaritan's purse which is a wonderful
charity
he has you know speaks all over the
world
travels all over the world but if you
actually google him what you'll find
is that franklin graham is somebody to
be feared
hated i think the last time i googled
him the first article that came up from
msnbc was 10 000 christian leaders call
on franklin graham to resign
because of his support for donald trump
there is a consistency in what they're
doing with these big tech
platforms that everything they do is
targeted
at christians it's targeted at
pro-lifers
it's targeted at conservatives
and it's uniform across across the board
this is uh just about the impact on
publishers
what we found from algorithm changes is
that
breitbart town hall daily caller
western journal that i run we were all
you know some of the most oppressed
publishers online came in and one day
saw our facebook traffic traffic drop a
full
90 percent 90.
the next day we were getting 10 percent
of the normal traffic and the only thing
that had changed
was donald trump was president
but it didn't just affect publishers yes
conservative publishers were
impacted but it also you know affected
uh republican politicians
so while facebook will say well we just
decided to make the uh
the platform less political and uh
you know so you should expect that
politics isn't going to be as widely
disseminated
this is the statistics on the change for
republican members of congress compared
to democrat members of congress
republicans saw their facebook
interaction go down 37 percent
while democrats only went down 27
percent
and in the senate it was even worse with
republican senators interactions on
facebook falling a
full 44 percent while democratic
senators only
saw their engagement fall by 31
so i i really could talk about uh the
impact of these algorithms on
conservatives and pro-lifers and
christians for for hours
but i want to get to one of the most
important issues i think that we
face and that is your privacy i started
with the discussion
with the the the use of
uh ovulation apps data being pulled into
facebook but
what you really need to understand is
most people think oh
you know i know that when i'm on the
facebook app
they're going to know what i'm clicking
and what i'm reading
but to really understand it you've got
to understand that is
just the beginning of it
and then i've had other people say well
i don't have facebook
so they don't track me i don't have
facebook i'm not on facebook
wrong facebook tracks
every american every single american
you don't have to have a facebook
account to be tracked by facebook
the truth is is that facebook tracks
everyone
and let me tell you how they do it see
the first
layer of the facebook data was
they sucked in every bit of
name address
email telephone numbers
they sucked in all the data they could
find on all americans from the very
beginning
and then they created a nexus with that
data between
uh your ip address or a lot of people
have several ip addresses
to find out how you were accessing
content online and then of course yes
if you are a member of facebook and
you've given them your
either your cell phone number or your
email address to become a member of
facebook they
they tie all of that in with your
facebook activity
but they're actually tracking all
americans
and it's really important to understand
their business model
on why they track all americans and the
reason they track all americans is
because when you go to
you know some website there's a good
chance
the ad on that website is being served
by
facebook same with google
it's being served by google so it
doesn't matter if you have a facebook
account
now it does greatly enhance their
ability to track
you if you do have a facebook account
and it'll even enhance more their
ability to track you if you use the
facebook app
on your phone which uh you know frankly
i think is a piece of spyware but let's
go through it
this is uh antonio garcia martinez
and he was really the the man behind
the product of facebook that really
started
this super invasion of privacy
so in the spring of 2013 he sold
facebook on a new
plan and uh really
it has echoes of bf skinner but facebook
now collects 1700
data points on every american
not every facebook user they collected
on every american
and then this data is compared across
platforms
to allow what they call the creation of
custom
audiences and this is what made facebook
so
unbelievably profitable
the truth is is that facebook makes
two hundred and twelve dollars for every
north american user now i know the
reason that they give you the data like
that is because the
they don't want you to know how
profitable
those usa users are because that's their
most
profitable set of users so they kind of
blend it with mexico and canada and all
of north america
and it's a very very profitable company
because they've created this product
called custom audiences
and what custom audiences does is it
allows
businesses to find people
that have the psychographic
blueprint similar to their current best
customers
so a business takes their current
customer list
and this is part of why facebook has so
much data because i bet you didn't
realize the businesses you do business
with are uploading their customer data
to facebook
but they are so they upload their
their customer list to facebook and they
say to facebook
find me people that think and act
like this customer list i have and so as
a result of that facebook's
algorithms begin spinning and spinning
and spinning
and they target like a rifle other
people
that think like their current customers
and companies will pay through the nose
for that kind
of enhanced marketing
data so that's what
mr martinez was able to develop
and it was the first time that marketers
could find people
on the platform exactly like their very
best customers it was extremely
profitable
and google i just you know i need to
talk about google
google has the very same product so
whether you're working with facebook or
you're working with
google they're collecting identical
troves of information about you
so what do google and facebook
know about you well
they know a lot the
first thing we all know they they know
what sites you're visiting
they know what kind of links you click
on regularly
and
they know when you switch from private
to public mode
you know some of you do have
you know use use some of your privacy
settings a lot of people don't use any
of them but if you do and you go to
incognito or private mode they know when
you switch in and out of it and what
you're doing when you switch in and out
of it
they know what videos you watch
partially they know what videos you
watch to the very end
they know how long you've been on that
video
and they know how quickly you move
from page to page so they know you know
what con
they know what content actually you
really find
interesting because you're spending time
there maybe you're reading
they know exactly where you are on the
page
most people don't understand that so if
you open an article and you read the
first paragraph
they know well they've read the first
paragraph you've read it all the way to
the end they know that
they know exactly what you're interested
in because of it
so um you know
they uh know how you know
how quickly you move from page to page
they know where you are physically
when you um
like where your physical location is so
they know that we're in this room
okay they know those of us who traveled
from around the country they know
that floyd brown traveled from phoenix
to hillsdale college they know that
about me
and so now they'll be able to put that
into
my psychographic profile now why in the
world would he go to hillsdale college
what is it about hillsdale that floyd
brown
really wanted to climb on an airplane
and go all the way to hillsdale
well they know why and and they can
they build these psychographic profiles
on you
so the the the truth is is that
that you know they know um
when you consume content and what kind
of content you consume at home
if you go to car starbucks and consume
content if you're on the go and you
consume content
if you're at work and you consume
content they know the different types of
content you consume
in these different places
so um they know the names of the people
that you're connecting with
online they
know what facial expressions you have
and yes that does include the use of
your video cam why do you think it's so
difficult
to buy a computer without a video cam
these days
it's almost impossible i have one but
you know you have to you have to you
have to really work
hard to get a
computer without a video cam and yes
they know what your facial expressions
are
they know how you react to different
things so one of the first things that i
encourage people to do
is get a cover for their video cam
you can order them online
that they're you know like 399 and you
slap it on your computer and then you
close off that video cam
and then they can't use it because you
have a physical barrier there
and it's it's it's it's one of the most
it's one of the single
most important privacy tools that uh
that i recommend i'm going to give you a
whole list of different privacy tools
that that that you should have but i
encourage you if you if you're looking
for a computer buy a computer without a
webcam
you can always get a portable webcam you
know so you can do your zoom call
and you can plug it in only when you use
it so it's not staring at you all the
time
and monitoring you all the time and
looking at you
all the time
so uh
the uh
the truth is is that uh they know your
facial expressions
they know how your skin tone changes in
different situations
uh they know um what you're doing
just before you decide to buy something
they know you know
when you leave a shopping cart and don't
buy something
they know what you're doing when you buy
something
they know what you're doing when you
decide not to buy something
they're tracking all of this information
very granular
information about every person
they know your political affiliations
and they know how active you are
in politics so one of the one of the
first things one of the first
bits of data that facebook
accumulated into its system was the
voter database
so most voter databases are available
publicly
if you you know if they're not available
publicly
in a state they're often marketed by
third parties
and so facebook took the entire voter
registration database of the of the
country
and ingested that into their facebook
system
so that was their first marker to know
you know how you how you uh react
politically and it's one of the most
profitable parts of what they do
are serving these detailed ads to
certain political
constituencies so
the uh
anybody surprised by any of this yet so
we're you know i uh
when i really started digging into this
i have to
admit it it's really scary
but um uh they they just track so many
things
where do you live you know where do you
like to go what are you gonna do next
where did you go to school do you keep
in touch with people from your school
you know are you single are you married
do you want to change that i mean they
know before your spouse
that you want to divorce
they know what you're thinking they know
what you're looking at
and they know if you're you're
questioning your sexuality
you know these are deep dark secrets to
a lot of people but
they know it so they know
what your birthday is they know the
birthday of
of your friends they know
about your current job they know whether
or not you want to
change jobs or if you're satisfied in
your job or if you're looking for
another job they
know about the birth dates of your
children
and they know what you like to do on the
birthday of your children
so and what did you spend money on
they just are tracking everything this
is one that i find particularly eerie
they know when you're going to die
they know all about your health a lot of
people now
you know wear different trackers to
track their physical fitness
and to you know know how many steps they
had
uh they they took yesterday or the day
before and uh some of those monitors you
know monitor
the you know your pulse rate
and a lot of people will go online and
they'll buy blood pressure
cuffs and those blood pressure cuffs
will have
apps that are attached to those blood
pressure cuffs
and so you can uh you know
take your blood pressure and then the
app is going to bluetooth
that data onto the app and that's going
to be sucked back down
into facebook because one of the most
profitable ways for these apps to make
money is by selling your data
and in almost all of the terms of
service you have agreed
to sell that data
so they know when you're gonna die
they know intimate details about your
health
if you're you know using google
calendars they know when you're
scheduled to go to your doctor
they know what you're doing where you
travel so
they they have all of these different
data points but what they do that's most
interesting is they cross
reference all of these data points to
find people that are
like you so
what you do not know can hurt you
and so i'd like to end by just talking a
little bit about some of the tools
you can use to protect yourself and to
try
and just blunt
blunt this invasive behavior
of these different tech giants because
it's important to understand
you are the product not the product
they're giving you
so i i encourage everybody
quit as much big tech as you can
i have a white paper on news
most of you probably will have consumed
at least
12 000 articles of online news in the
last year
some of you much much more than that uh
the truth is is that probably
the content of those 12 000
articles that you read will have
virtually no
impact on your lifestyle if you didn't
know that information probably wouldn't
change your life
one bit so
you know it's okay to read a physical
book
it's okay to read a magazine article
from a physical magazine it's okay
to not consume all of your content on
these platforms
they have convinced us that oh well i
don't need to subscribe to a magazine
anymore because
i can just read that stuff for free
online
it's not free you're giving away your
privacy in exchange for that free
article
it's not free because you are the
product
and what you're reading is the product
so quit big tech if you can most people
will say well you know i would quit big
tech if i could but i can't do it
so let me just give you a few things you
can do
do not use google products
do not if you have the chrome browser
i want you to go home and delete it
use the foxfire browser you'll still be
tracked there'll still be some tracking
but it's
nothing like the the google's chrome
browser
google's chrome browser literally
rapes its customers of all of their
private data
and i don't use that word flippantly
don't use facebook don't use twitter
and don't use the instagram apps
now you can still visit twitter
you can still visit facebook you can
still visit
instagram just don't do it
on their apps
a lot of people don't realize this so um
one of the one of the reasons that uh
online news sites are so profitable
is because of the facebook app
because people download the facebook app
and they don't realize they think that
the facebook app is tracking them
when they're on the facebook app no
the facebook is the app is tracking you
all the time it's one of the reasons
it's one of the biggest
power hogs on your smartphone so if you
have the facebook app
it's literally tracking everything you
do all the time you do it
it knows what other sites you're going
to it is getting a detailed profile of
you
even if you're not on the facebook app
so delete that
app immediately and you can go to
facebook on a browser
you don't have to use their app to do it
you don't have to use the twitter app
you don't have to use the instagram app
you can do it without the apps
and just do it in one of your browsers
and you'll have
much much just doing that one thing will
enhance your privacy
dramatically so
use a secondary app to follow social
media
and to search online you know don't
search at google
uh if you're if you're in a browser go
to start
page start page will give you
google search results right out of
google but they won't track you
the way google will track you and uh
you know ducked up go is another one now
duckduckgo gives you
bing results from the the search
website that microsoft has bing but um
it's also another great app you can put
on your phone and stop
searching with google now
your your your iphone
google pays apple
an astronomical amount of money so that
when you search on the iphone you're
searching in google
so that they can know more detailed
about you so
if you have an iphone stop searching
in google but use one of these other
apps like duckduckgo
or superfeed superfeed is one of my
favorites
superfeed allows you to follow social
media
in a different app that's that that
isn't tracking you
so for example one of the things i found
the most frustrating
during this last year was the twitter
suppression of donald trump
i wanted to know what donald trump was
tweeting right
and i couldn't get it on twitter
because twitter would only give you a
selection
that they chose of donald trump's tweets
on their actual platform so donald
trump's sitting there you know
tweeting things out and twitter's
suppressing him
so you if you're on twitter and you're
trying to
get what donald trump's tweeting you
cannot get it on the platform
but this app superfeed if you followed
the donald trump minifeed
you could actually see what he was
saying on twitter
and you weren't being tracked by twitter
so
and superfeeds available in the ios
store and in the android store and it's
it's it's a it's a great way to consume
news
without being tracked you know don't use
do not use apple news do not use google
news
do not use these big tech products
because they are just in they're just
they're spyware
enhanced tracking of everything you do
and think and read
please do not use gmail
i implore you don't use gmail
okay when you use gmail they read your
mail
they have total rights to read whatever
you're emailing
and that's not just the emails that you
send
it's also the emails that come to you
from other people
they read everything
now they they'll say oh well we don't
you know personally track
no they know everything so
please use an email from a cable company
and the cable company will try and track
you but they're not very good at it
so you know better yet get yourself a
secure service i use one called
protonmail.com
so protonmail is completely secure
they have their servers in a mountain
somewhere in switzerland
and uh they uh
you know specialize in private email
so you know i also people come up and
ask me well what about yahoo well
yahoo tracks you too it's owned by
verizon
and you know like a cable company the
cellular companies
you know aren't quite as good at
tracking as google is they haven't
refined the art as well but still
i i wouldn't use you know products are
not free
people get this idea well yeah i have a
free email
and i have this free and i have that no
you don't you
are the product you're the product
so limit your time on your phone
limit the time consuming content online
i know these things are hard to do and
you know we love to
watch it but my last point there
is the most important and that is
enjoy people directly talk to someone
go have coffee with someone go to church
meet people face to face
don't text them talk to them
don't be just online but be a real
human and you will do a lot to protect
yourself
thank you and i'll open it up to any
questions
[Applause]
thank you mr brown we now have some time
for q and a
so if you have a question please make
your way to one of the microphones
my favorite time is the question time by
the way
i used to be a radio talk show host and
i loved talking to the callers
so thank you so much for coming i was
just wondering what made you trust some
of these apps more than google and
facebook and other things like that
i'm sorry i had a little trouble hearing
you what makes you trust these abs
instead
of the other ones oh you mean superfeed
and duckduckgo
because both of those apps were
developed
by privacy nuts in order to try and get
you more privacy okay that's the whole
purpose of those apps
like with superfeed you don't if you
want to just use it basically
you don't even create an account okay
the minute you create account with a
company
that's usually a marker that they're
gonna you know
start downloading data about you so they
all want you to create an account and
get a password and they want you to stay
logged in all the time
superfeed doesn't do that duckduckgo i
don't believe
does that so it's really
it's really much better privacy wise if
you don't
log in that's why i trust him
hi i wanted to ask what the legality and
veracity are
of permissions because when you said the
facebook thing about tracking i checked
mine
and it says that i have the location on
only while app is in use
is that true because to be fair this is
a google phone
as well so uh
yeah so if you've actually physically
gone and turned off your location
tracking
then uh hopefully they're not tracking
you
okay but most people never
look into the privacy portions of their
apps and they
they use just the basic settings which
would be to track you
we have time for one more question
hello thank you so much for coming to
our school i
was wondering google seems to be
providing an excellent service
by tailoring search results to us and
having targeted ads what is the actual
harm besides just like
us being a product in targeted ads and
tailored searches
yeah what's the actual harm
that's a good question that's a really
good question the um
and i i talk about this question a lot
with my son okay my son's a millennial
and uh and he says i don't have anything
to hide
so it's okay that they know everything
about me there's
you know i don't i don't i don't have
anything to hide
but um you know the the truth is
is that
i i think i personally don't like people
being in my brain like that
and um the uh yes and
and the control elements you know the
the ability to
serve me certain ads because they know
that i'm going to click on that ad
because they know the way
i think and the way my mind works
so you know frankly i've missed having
you know highly customized ads
that are tailored just for me i haven't
missed them
i haven't missed them all they will make
you do is probably consume
more than you want to consume spend
more than you want to spend and
and in the case of pornography do things
you probably
wouldn't want to do online so that's the
harm
please join me in thanking mr brown
oh